Max Scherzer goes for the Dodgers 37
year old right-hander 15 in four during
the regular season made 30 starts with a
246 era now Tyler O'Neill
bursting onto the scene this year 34
homers
Fly ball to right that's on the run that
short wall over there and that's makes a
catch Colts Runners tag Goldsmith stops
Edmund ends up at third terrific play by
Mookie Betts handling that four foot
wall Now aronado with an RBI opportunity
he's in protect mode now Otto and two
with Runners at first and third from the
high set the pitch by Scherzer outside
and it gets away from the catcher Will
Smith Tommy Edmond scores down to Second
goes Paul Goldschmidt one nothing
Cardinals shares her on one and two to
aronado
and a Fly ball to left center field
fairly deep Pollock is there and makes
the catch in front of Cody Bellinger in
left Center and there's two out first
and third two out here's Yadier Molina
coming up Cardinals one to nothing two
out first and third the great Yadier
Molina
with a Fly ball into center field
drifting toward left Center Bellinger's
underneath it he's there to make the
catch and that will end the inning
however the Cardinals come up with one
run 40 year old right-hander Adam
Wainwright who is 17-7 during the
regular year with a 305 era making his
29th career posting his appearance
here's the MVP of the 2020 NLCS and
World Series Corey Seger Trey Turner is
on Deck followed by Justin Turner One
nothing Cardinals the pitch
and strike three called on the inside
corner Seeger is out looking
now Justin Turner
Justin Turner and his 73rd career
postseason game that's 295 19 doubles a
triple 12 Homer's 41 RBIs the man can
flat out hit he represents a go-ahead
run batting with a runner at first and
two outs in the first inning there's a
shot right back to Wayne Right he caught
it how did he catch it I thought that
was going to nail him in the side he got
the glove out there and said look what I
have just a reaction by the way right
Fernando Sosa the rookie shortstop will
lead off this second inning three and
two the count shares their deals and a
swinging out of this a strikeout for
Scherzer that is his first a big
strikeout pitcher when he's right and
now Tommy Edmond coming up now the pitch
to Edmond batting from the left side
so I Ain't Gonna Fly ball into short
left sprinting in and over toward the
line Pollux underneath it'll make the
catch and that'll in the inning here's
Will Smith 26 year old catcher out of
Louisville Smith hit 258 this year and
he hit 25 home runs driving in 76.
the wind-up another 3-2 pitch swinging a
ground ball up the middle that's
backhanded by Tommy Edmond his throw he
got him unbelievable
Tyler O'Neill coming up now the O2
swagon had missed strike three
second strikeout of the game for
Scherzer first out of the third and here
is Dylan Carlson now here's the 2-2
granted to First nice play by fadia
maybe a foot inside the line steps on
the bag and the inning is over
so far so good defensively for Matt
Beatty at first base and that loads the
bases for Trey Turner a big pitch for
Wainwright
and he's going to have a few more
a 3-2 delivery
to Turner is grounded up the middle
Tommy Edmond has it he kicks the bag
throws the first double play
unbelievable Wainwright gets out of it a
broken bet grounder up the middle Edmund
kicked the bag through to First and the
Cardinals somehow get through the third
inning that brings up Adam Wainwright
no balls in two strikes
Vader good speed at first
Scherzer delivers and Wainwright Strikes
Out Swinging and that will end the end
for sure his third strikeout of the game
no runs no hits one man left through
three and a half and the wild card game
it's the Cardinals one of the Dodgers
nothing Justin Turner will lead it off
he line right back to the Box in his
first Outback
Wainwright deals Turner in the air left
field he's going to watch it fly
Turner strikes in
[Applause]
Justin Turner with one Mighty wallow
into the Dodger Bullpen the score is
tied at one
tied at one here in the fourth inning
and Will Smith will bet the O2 delivery
to Will Smith is uh called strike three
inside corner and Smith doesn't like it
but he gets the ring up that's two
strikeouts for Wainwright
and that'll bring in AJ Pollock three
for eight against Wainwright in his
career oh for one here tonight a little
half swing did he go and he is gone AJ
Pollock is rung up
and Wainwright comes back with back to
back case Tyler O'Neal with 34 home runs
this year he knocked in 80. Cardinals
first and second nobody out the 1-2
plug on and Miss strike three
fourth strikeout of the game for sure
sir
and the first out of the fifth
comes Dave Roberts springing out of the
Dodger Dugout is Dave Roberts
and he's trying to take the ball
Scherzer shakes his hand and scherzer's
Out Boy this is a move here that is
going to be talked about brings up Dylan
Carlson
now the pitch
plug on and missed strike three and that
will end the inning and here's Bellinger
Bellinger walked and was left at third
base Wainwright deals big swing at a
Miss by Bellinger and there is out
number one as Wainwright
picks up a strikeout his fourth and
that's his third in the last four
batters faced now it's Luke Rayleigh
stepping in
the 1-2 pitch from Adam Wainwright swing
and a miss Adam struck him out
five strikeouts for Wainwright and four
of the last five batters great Turner
coming up three and two
and a slow and roll are gonna be a tough
chance arnado has no play Trey Turner
with an infield hit Mike Shields is
going to take the ball from Adam
Wainwright how to make that move so it
turns it out win right out a go ahead
run is Trey Turner at second base with
AJ Pollock coming up
two and one the count with two on a
one-to-one game bottom of the sixth the
pitch to pollock a swing and a little
tap up the first base line fielded by
Garcia he throws and Goldsmith somehow
made the catch over Pollock's shoulder I
don't know how goldsmic caught that with
the throw by Garcia over the shoulder
and Goldsmith got his arm out of the way
just in time to get the out on Pollock
1-3 now Garcia has to deal with mookie
bets Garcia trying to close out the
inning swing and a Fly ball to center
field Harrison Bader calls everybody off
waves everybody off makes the play and
Garcia gets through the Innings tonight
is over three
and he drills one into left field but
Chris Taylor makes the catch on the
surface of the grass
it was a shoe top I mean he just went
down
to the grass and made the play and
there's two out and that is a much more
difficult play than what it appeared to
be and especially in the crucial
situation Will Smith can clock a mistake
and the delivery to Smith has hit hard
and it's caught by the young he left in
the air and uh grabbed it and that'll
end the bottom of the eighth inning nice
job Paul he needs here's Goldsmith one
for two in a couple of walks tonight and
Jensen set and delivers
call strike three now two out and Tyler
O'Neal
set and delivers swung on and missed
strike three and that'll end the inning
Here Comes Albert pools who's riding
this
cool is in the center field and the
knuckleball out there back is Bader he's
got it played it well that had a funky
rotation to it Alex Reyes
on to pitch for St Louis with two outs
in the bottom of the ninth inning and
now here's Taylor with a chance to be a
hero
Reyes fires swinging a drive deep left
field this is way back welcome off Chris
Taylor the Dodgers are walking off to
San Francisco they win the wild card
three to one
[Applause]